you
my name is Jennifer koron
Lanna professor of marketing at the
Stanford Graduate School of Business and
I authored the book the Dragonfly effect
I'm Andy Smith I'm a principal of
vulnerable debentures and I also
authored the Dragonfly effect
we looked at at the market and thought
there was a gap there's a lot of books
on Twitter there's a lot of books on
different aspects of marketing and a lot
of books on psychology but we didn't see
a book that brought it all together in a
way that people could actually put to
work for a particular goal and that's
exactly what we we try to do we blend in
enough information about social media to
get people over the hump of
understanding and understand how it's
more like traditional media than they
might have originally thought and enough
about how individuals behave and are
motivated such that they might be able
to construct a particular appeal to them
enough about how marketing actually
works to move through the processes of
awareness and commitment and involvement
so that someone can actually convert
someone to purchase or to donate or to
participate in a cause and Andy's been
interested in social media for a long
time often saying that social media is
the only marketing that you can't buy so
I thought it was interesting but at the
end of the day I thought it was really a
waste of time initially I thought it was
very difficult to understand why people
would be spending their time harnessing
Facebook Twitter video and it wasn't
until I I heard a story by one of my
students
Robert shot Hwanhee who told the story
of his 32 year old best friend Sameer
Bhatia who had leukemia and what Robert
and Roberts friends and family and
Samir's friends and family did is tackle
a single focused goal which in Samir's
case was how do you find a bone marrow
match the doctors told them that there
was a 1 in 20,000 chance that they would
find a bone marrow match for Sameer so
smears friends and family took that as a
very simple business challenge which is
how are we going to get 20,000 Southeast
Asians in the bone marrow registry they
only had up weeks to do so and they
harness social media along with
traditional means to get in fact twenty
four thousand six
11 Southeast Asians in the bone marrow
registry in 11 weeks it was an
incredible story where you know I would
hear that a friend has leukemia what
could I do I would think could I bring
them a lasagna could I help babysit
their kids and what Robert and Samir's
friends and family dead was life
changing and in fact they found a
perfect match for Samir and ultimately
just in the year after that effort
matched with 266 other individuals just
based on those twenty four thousand six
hundred and eleven individuals
registered into that bone marrow
registry in eleven weeks so it was
incredible story that was told to me and
I think it really changed the way I saw
how social media could be effective and
what was also an opportunity we saw here
was that rather than have this simply be
an anecdotal story Robert jawani had
left us with a toolkit essentially that
showed how he did it it wasn't just that
they they did it it was an amazing
amazing feat it was that he'd created
created a methodology which outlined
specifically the things of the emphasize
at each stage and how they took the
effort beyond themselves beyond the
people were directly affected to a wider
scope and so when the opportunity came
to to write this up to do something with
it
I thought that it was particularly
incumbent on us to put into a way that
other people could use so that someone
else who has a friend who's Donna Wilkie
Mia it doesn't have to be as amazingly
talented and original and motivated
actually they need the motivation but
they didn't have to invent it from
scratch and that was one of the one of
the principles that came out of out of
his work was to make it so that
everything was invented once the toolkit
that they used to inspire people and to
help people do their own bone marrow
drives was something that they created
once and they rolled out many times and
they templated every every everything
based on their own experience here's the
message you need to send to the CEO of
the company you work for here's the
message you need to send to Human
Resources here's how you get in touch
with the the registry organization that
will actually provide the donor kits
here's how you get it done and you know
just search and replace fill in
different blanks and you know you've got
a bone marrow drive in a box or social
change in a box more broadly and then
what we did was we took a lot of the
principles we do research on the
psychology of happiness the psychology
of motivation why people are motivated
along with some of the tools we know
from the research on orgs coms how are
they perceived how do people become
effective in organizational settings and
that became the basis of the book
the message of this book is that you
don't need a tremendous amount of
resources to make a remarkable amount of
change and that if you can take Robert
as the example he was an individual who
was faced with you know an unacceptable
situation his friend was dying and he
didn't have a tremendous amount of money
or other resources to put against it but
he had an amazing amount of will and
smarts and that's essentially what we
see the Dragonfly effect powering if
you've got something that is singular
and clear and focused and you've got the
will to do it the technology is there to
make it happen and a clearer
understanding of the way things work in
social space will help it actually get
done and it doesn't matter whether you
are the individual such as Robert or a
large company if you've got a a mission
an idea that can capture the imagination
and the interest of people well beyond
yourself and well beyond your
organization you have an opportunity to
make something big happen so the basic
model the Dragonfly is based on four
wings the first wing is focus which is
what is your single clear objective goal
it has to be measurable the mere thought
of achieving that goal should make you
happy at some level the second wing is
grab attention what makes people look
and and there's a series of design
principles that help define what really
grabs attention the third wing is
potentially more difficult which is how
do you engage how do you make people
feel truly connected to the cause the
organization to the goal itself and that
has a lot to do with storytelling with
authenticity with personal connection
and then the final wing is take action
or how do you enable others to act so
that the focused goal is not just
something that you have but others share
and ultimately win these four small acts
or four wings act in concert the
dragonfly lips and the dragonfly is the
only insect that can fly in any
direction when all four wings are acting
in Khan's
so it's a it's it's a good metaphor for
the ideas that we're trying to convey in
the book it's also a symbol of happiness
and change which are the seeds of the
research they are also embedded in the
book
one story that they caught our attention
about a year ago was a story of the
Montana Meth project it was a project
spearheaded by Tom Siebel who who found
that that by spending a lot of time in
Montana he noticed that that in
conversations with folks and law
enforcement that there was a
disproportionate amount of crimes that
were caused by meth related activities
and there was literally an epidemic
status in in the state and so he took it
upon himself to to address the question
of why and what can be done about it and
what he took was a relatively
businesslike approach or very
businesslike approach to to getting
things done first of all he said about
identifying what was his goal in terms
of and doing this and it was really
clear it was like reduce the incidence
of meth in in Montana and but in doing
that had to figure out where where was
it a problem where did it lead to
long-term effects and went through a
very methodical process where they
identified that that people adults may
be doing meth but they did it they
started doing it when there were teens
and so targeted specifically focusing on
teens to basically cut out cut out the
root of of the instance and then they
also went forward and said well why why
haven't previous efforts worked to
reduce this and it was that the people
who are in this market are highly
influenced by advertising but not by
advertising that are put in the typical
PSA space or in the typical this is your
brain on drugs space and they really
went and once the trouble understanding
what grab people's attention what would
someone who was considering meth a
teenager in high school who was about to
try it for the first time you know what
was the thing that would get their
attention and they struck upon this
message of of not even once and you know
they the the story that was told was you
know among among meth addicts you know
what was the thing that you wish you
could do to tell you know your younger
brother or your younger friend you know
what not to do and it was that don't
even try it once
they used that story and rolled it out
in a very effective methodical way and
when they looked at their metrics they
had a dramatic impact reducing reducing
methods and method senses among the
target group just phenomenal and as a
result the project isn't has been rolled
out to multiple states and they've made
that they made the tools and the and the
learnings of available to state drug
enforcement organizations you know for
the past five years
we hope that people who pick with a book
will put it to use it is more than
collection of stories to us it's it is a
as an action plan for getting things
done and the more the more people that
that take it on that find creative ways
to deploy social technology social media
in support of things that people beyond
themselves beyond the organization's
believe it worthwhile we hope that they
will in turn add to our our
knowledgebase
add to the sort of the collective idea
of what works in this space and we we
intend this to be used we we hope that
people will will buy it and put it to
work and then you know help us help us
make it even better and I think from a
for-profit perspective one of the most
exciting things about the book is the
employees or executives that read this
book I think have a different way of
thinking about building our brand
building a brand through storytelling
through principles of authenticity and
also building a brand that enables
others to take action so not just
employees but also customers how did
they help build that brand so it's a
more of a community focus way of brand
building and then from a nonprofit
perspective there's so many nonprofits
that have a strong mission and a single
focused goal already but the book is
intended as an Andy says to be a roadmap
to make them even more effective